this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be checking
out the varied weaponry of rockstar's
crime classic grand theft auto 5. okay
paul's there because we have a splendid
view of the hilarious hand-drawn sight
reticle that i'm going to assume this
was made by trevor i mean it's such a
spectacularly bad idea why not do it
with some style if there are any other
games guns and mechanics that you guys
want to see jonathan break down let us
know in the comment section below be
sure to subscribe for more videos like
this one and if you'd like to help out
the royal army's museum and continue to
support jonathan's work check out the
links in the description of this video
right over to jonathan
well i i knew this going in this is
grand theft auto of course but this
thing is actually more wacky than it
looks so apart from not really
resembling any real firearms looks a
little bit p7 but based on what this is
supposed to be i'm not sure that's
intentional what's funky about it is
that when the slide locks open it locks
open really far back it's almost as
though a grand theft auto game hasn't
thought through the mechanics of a
firearm and it's so far back on the gun
that it it's not going to work properly
so it doesn't quite function as it ought
to it's got the name shrewsbury or
shrewsbury sorry on the side which is a
town in england i'm assuming that's
meant to be the maker so i'm interesting
backstory potentially that i'm not aware
of there
all right another alleged product of the
shrewsbury firearms company which has a
rather nice red deer stag logo by the
look of it appropriately british i
suppose um the gun however isn't gun is
very clearly based on a saiga 12
kalashnikov pattern 12 gauge
or in this case 12 gouache because among
among other pedantic aspects of my
personality spelling and grammar is
definitely are definitely two of them
and point is they misspelled the word
gage no that might be a deliberate
mistake but it's quite funny that it's
there so in very close detail this will
be a theme this is not a super close
match for the saga 12 it's based on but
the general silhouette is basically the
same and it performs much as you've seen
the saga 12 in other games before it's a
gas operated semi-automatic shotgun
pretty devastating but much more of a
competition shotgun really than a
tactical one having said that i've
definitely seen russian special forces
or security forces toting them around so
they are actually used for fighting
purposes
[Music]
all right next up we've got an ak
blinged out if i can bring myself to use
that
and the butt stock tells us right away
that this is meant to be a chinese type
56-2 which is the side bowling buttstock
version of the chinese copy of the ak
but it's been kind of carteled up pretty
severely with some somehow kind of
carving and relief on the sheet metal
receiver which i think would be a really
bad idea okay so i think a bit of a
quirk of the game's design heritage as a
third person kind of lock-on shooter is
that there's not a huge amount of recoil
evident this ak is pretty laser laser
accurate really there's not the classic
climb up into the right that you'd
expect from
well the real thing actually never mind
um the virtual version the first person
view which i never experienced looks
pretty good but has has the classic
issue of the sights not being aligned so
um you're using just the front sight to
aim the rear sight is not equal height
equal light as we as we tend to say it
just kind of sits there looking pretty
[Music]
this is a really odd one uh especially
because this is one of the standard
pistols in the game so you see it in the
hands of agents and all sorts of things
whereas you'd expect to see something
like a glock of course and it's some
sort of really wacky
machine pistol fully automatic pistol
totally fictional i mean you could try
and compare it to a few designs that
appeared over the years but i would
probably question all of those i think
this is an entirely original or as close
to entirely original as you can get for
a video game for a nine millimeter
machine pistol so in the world of gta
everyone and their mum is running around
with a machine pistol which i suppose
fits
that kind of checks out with the level
of responsibility with firearms that
people in gta games tend to show yeah
this thing is far too controllable it's
quite a weak stance that the players got
there a bit of a bit of a weaver style
stance not sufficient to support
something that would be doing
anything from 900 rounds per minute up
not very controllable the muzzle would
rise very very quickly there are people
with the skill to control such things
i'm not sure our guys are are those guys
yeah and then as if the um dodgy pistol
stance wasn't insufficient enough blind
firing one-handed around the corner with
a fully automatic pistol well i mean it
happens in the criminal front of
fraternity don't get me wrong but um you
would be hitting even less than the
player here is hitting probably mainly
the sky and then potentially some poor
people slash property slash pets down
the road where the bullets land not a
good idea for anyone really
no that's pause can't take it
oh lord okay so rpg-7 as i'm sure
everyone has spotted with a weird
hexagonal breech shield on the back
there
that should be a flat round
plate around the breech otherwise it's
reasonably correct but of course this
one is neon pink with a white heat
shield so they have modelled here a
something approximating a pg-7 munition
the back end doesn't look right it looks
like a pipe bomb what it should be is a
cardboard sleeve over some flick out
metal fins which we don't see deploy
when the thing is shot it it
shoots like a rocket does so this is
what should be a recoilless weapon with
a rocket-assisted munition is depicted
as a rocket launcher which is entirely
expected interestingly in first person
view we see the sights being used here
somewhat realistically so we're aiming
over using one of the higher settings
but with this delightful pink paint job
and i'm not sure if the site markings
are there normally you have no site
markings to be sure how many meters
you're shooting out to but it seems to
allow you to aim it with a bit more
precision than in third person
i ain't leave down for them
get out of here
i've seen a couple as well as shrewsbury
the um apparently british firearms maker
we've got this um von foyer company
which i am informed i mean i was aware
of what foyer meant fire vom is
apparently the word from so
from fire not an inappropriate name for
a german firearms manufacturer and there
are at least two german firearms
manufacturer who make ar-15 patent
rifles like this one although this one
appears to be an a us-made voltore upper
receiver i think very chunky blocky
looking thing others have copied it and
that big chunky round rail that almost
looks fake but i think it's meant to be
a daniel defense mfr which stands for
modular float rail floated meaning that
the rail doesn't contact the barrel at
any point in other words this is
actually a fairly legitimate setup the
colors are a bit screwy silver bolts are
not uncommon silver dust covers are a
bit and then the white stock is kind of
weird yeah for this game it's a fairly
spot-on
interpretation of a modern ar1500
[Music]
this is clearly closely based on the m82
m107 barrett maybe with some bits of
accuracy international thrown in i'm not
sure the weight the weight handles isn't
spot on the magazine should rock in not
just not just slap in for example
so interestingly the effect of this
thing on target is less than i would
expect for such an over-the-top game as
gta the poor unfortunate struck by the
enormous bullet
simply drop in place they don't go
flying back as so many in video games do
another example of gta walking an
interesting line between dare i say
realism and um absolute insanity in some
cases one real world advantage of big
powerful rifles like the barrett is that
they allow users to engage targets
behind cover doesn't look like they've
modeled that so the thin steel of a bus
should be absolutely no problem for a 50
bmg round should basically go straight
through
pretty much unaffected and then hit
whatever's on the other side so if you
know someone's there you should be able
to hit them
[Applause]
right this is in real life the kel tec
ksg which is a dual magazine tube single
barrel 12 gauge shotgun massive fudge on
the reload on this thing possibly the
other shotguns in the game i'm not sure
a single cartridge introduced to one of
the magazine tubes is sufficient to
reload the complete weapon somehow so
that really does feel like a throwback
to
what's meant to be a fun throwaway third
person shooting experience where
suddenly we're having to model it in in
first person and for whatever reason
we're not showing even like a super high
speed comedy sped up shoving in all the
rounds we don't even get that we just
get one round needless to say that's
that wouldn't
i don't wish to be too critical but this
might be the weakest
the weakest sounding
and recoiling desert eagle i've ever
seen in a game looks pretty close
for the mark 19 50 caliber but the the
sound effect isn't particularly punchy
at least not on my speakers and it
doesn't recoil like the real thing does
so i think we've got i think we've had a
limitation here of a third person game
turned into first person okay so we go
back to the classic third person view
with trevor here we see a much more
exaggerated much more accurate depiction
of how this thing flips at least the 50
caliber version how this thing muzzle
flips quite quite dramatically nothing
much you can do about that even if you
are quite strong so it looks much more
meaty and
realistic from the third-person view
not great from the first
[Music]
[Music]
so not what i remember from the game but
we are looking of course at a riff on
the g36 hecarim [ __ ] g36 556 rifle the
trigger group has different shape grip
these things don't have the option like
an ar-15 of different separate grips to
swap out we're stuck with whatever's on
that trigger group details at the
trigger are obviously not right it's got
a version of the classic
hk b and t
folding butt stock but it's different i
get very much a sense of
legal difference from this thing but
what's not
wrong per se i don't think is the
magazine set up so the classic g36 has a
rockin magazine arrangement
but because it is modular you can
replace the magazine well
with a
stanag or m16 so this will take ar15 and
16 magazines
as well as its own
translucent ones that it comes with and
it has the catch
here so the weird-looking magazine
arrangement with a straight magazine
although it's not a match for this by
any means is something that has a
parallel in reality but it's it's a it's
a fudge overall to look
deliberately different
working pretty much as we'd expect
except that it's firing from from the
closed bolt which the mini uzi does not
unless it's a
semi-automatic version now i remember
this as one of the classic gta weapons
that you can use while driving exactly
what we see happening here i mean it's a
staple of action movies of course to
drive one hand and shoot with the other
not so convenient with the old stick
shift that most of us in europe are it's
gonna say stuck with but i'm a fan but
it does limit your ability to
shoot while driving which otherwise you
could do um to what effect probably
depends on your familiarity with
shooting whilst driving you'd at least
put some heads down i dare say
[Music]
i feel i have to introduce this one
as
it's a damn minigun name that film i'm
sure you already have uh it looks a
little chunky the barrel cluster looks a
little bit enormous but short i don't
know if the proportions are quite right
but then the whole gun is a sort of
pastiche of that terminator 2
predator gun in gta like so many video
games it's just handheld it has no means
of being powered it has no means of
being fed with ammunition it just
magically spawns rounds and fires them
and then magically ejects the casings
but then you know i i can completely see
how trying to model all of that for a
game where you pull guns out of thin air
just isn't worth it so
i get it so yeah as expected zero recoil
on this thing they haven't even bothered
to try and implement it it's like it's
on a pedestal mount which which of
course directs all the recoil forces
through to multiple bolted arms on the
floor of something very solid this is
very much
fantasyland
there's a strong tradition in the gta
games of fudging weapons generally but
certainly in my memory the the smgs
which have been based on numerous
designs over the years this one is kind
of the love child of an mp5 with that
telescoping buttstock curved magazine
the cocking handle where it is
and
probably this thing
it's got the angular
receiver the dimples over the magazine
well not entirely convinced but it's
it's a mashup of it's not a
straightforward mp5 at least alright so
what's this well this is the um chilean
f-a-m-a-e-s-a-f
bit of a mouthful but i think there's
probably at least a family resemblance
here and it's something different that
we've not looked at before they all
function pretty similarly not an ideal
thing to be engaging armored opponents
with so these guys are meant to be
professional even if it's just soft body
armor which it i guess it might well be
pistol ammunition such as fired by both
of these not ideal and yet we these guys
go down like um nine pins
[Applause]
[Music]
okay paul's there because we have a
splendid view from first person of the
hilarious hand-drawn sight reticle that
i'm going to assume this was made by
trevor that he has scrawled onto a piece
of plastic glass
set into the
back blast shield on what is actually a
fairly hilarious cardboard copy of the
panzer shrek
which is behind me i don't propose to
wave about on camera
it's pretty close in basic configuration
why why you would base an improvised
rocket launcher on panzer shrek rather
than anything else i don't know i mean
it's such a spectacularly bad idea why
not do it with some style
right not a common find on the streets
of la or well i guess it is on the
streets of los santos this is the
russian originally soviet pkm or
something close to it um the barrel
looks a bit short the gas system
definitely looks too short i think the
stock's wrong but um it's clearly based
on that now we've got two different feed
devices on this thing there's a
classic pkm pk style ammo box it's not
it's not an it's not a magazine it just
holds the belt of ammunition
and then
similarly but incorrectly we've got the
equivalent feed device the round box
thing from the rpd the
smaller 762 by 39 russian light machine
gun they've clearly put those in for a
bit of unlockable upgradable variety and
as i say this i'm sure someone somewhere
has got a round drum
on a pk type like machine gun general
purpose machine gun but it's not normal
needless to say but then what about gta
is normal pick it up mikey my guns get
hot
we have as always links in the
description to the royal armouries
website various things going on social
media and on-site at our three museums
if you'd like to donate to us we really
appreciate that and there's a link there
to do that as well there's no pressure
at all and we will see you again next
time
[Music]
you